Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply.
家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日促销活动现已开启，您的夏天从现在开始。是时候用下一代烧烤架开启夏日烧烤了，四头燃气烧烤架特价仅需199美元。整个季节都可以用仅售49美元的Hampton Bay West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅来招待亲友。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期至5月14日或5月27日。仅限美国，受条款限制。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. When you think of humans working with robots, what comes to mind? Futuristic images of robot assistance? Or maybe R2D2 and C3PO from Star Wars? In reality, robots and other autonomous systems are already around us, in doctors' offices, in the military, in our homes, and in the cars we drive. Now, as humans increasingly incorporate robots and other autonomous systems into our daily lives, Psychologists are studying how the science of teamwork can help us maximize the benefits
详情请见HomeDepot.com价格匹配页面。当您想到人类与机器人合作时，会想到什么？是机器人辅助的未来景象？还是《星球大战》中的R2D2和C3PO？实际上，机器人和其他自主系统已经存在于我们身边，在医生办公室、军队、家中以及我们驾驶的汽车里。现在，随着人类越来越多地将机器人和其他自主系统融入日常生活，心理学家们正在研究团队合作科学如何帮助我们最大化收益，
and minimize the pitfalls of working on human robot teams. So how common are human robot teams today? How to trust and collaboration differ when people are working with robots or other autonomous systems versus with other people? What role are robots playing in the military, in medicine, and in other complex high-stakes arenas? And as humans increasingly rely on robots and artificial intelligence in our lives and workplaces, might we lose some skills that we used to have? How can psychological research help us avoid that?
并最小化在人机团队中工作带来的隐患。那么，如今人机团队有多普遍？当人们与机器人或其他自主系统合作时，与与他人合作相比，信任和协作有何不同？机器人在军事、医疗和其他复杂的高风险领域中扮演什么角色？随着人类在生活和工作中越来越依赖机器人和人工智能，我们是否会失去曾经拥有的一些技能？心理学研究如何帮助我们避免这种情况？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Erica Rivera, a professor of engineering psychology and the Department of behavioral sciences and leadership at the United States Military Academy West Point. She studies how humans interact with robots and AI in high-risk complex environments like the military and aviation. Her work has been funded by the Department of Defense and other government agencies, and she was recently awarded a five-year multi-university research initiative grant
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天的嘉宾是西点军校行为科学与领导力系工程心理学教授埃里卡·里维拉（Dr. Erica Rivera）博士。她研究人类如何在军事和航空等高风险、复杂的环境中与机器人和人工智能互动。她的工作得到了国防部和其他政府机构的资助，最近她还获得了为期五年的多大学研究计划资助，
to study human autonomous teeming. She's the author of many peer-reviewed journal articles and co-editor of the book, Living with Robots, Emerging Issues on the Psychological and Social Implications of Robotics. Dr. Revere, thank you for joining me today. Kim, thank you for having me. I'm very excited to talk to you today about human robot teaming. Yeah, me too. A moment ago, I talked about working with robots in your research. You used the phrase human autonomy teams.
用于研究人类与自主系统的协作。她是许多同行评审期刊文章的作者，也是《与机器人共存：机器人技术的心理和社会影响中的新兴问题》一书的共同编辑。里维拉博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。金，谢谢你的邀请。我很高兴今天能和你谈谈人机协作。是的，我也是。刚才我提到了你在研究中与机器人合作，你使用了“人类自主团队”这个词。
What does that mean? What's autonomy in that phrase? What does that refer to? Sure, autonomous teams or autonomy specifically is without human intervention. So having a robot agent that can perform tasks independently. And so when I talk about human autonomous teams, it's the integration of this robot agent, this autonomous agent with a human partner. And how common are these teams today and what are some of the situations where humans and robots are already working together?
那是什么意思？这个词组中的“自主”是指什么？它指的是什么？当然，自主团队或自主性具体是指无需人工干预。即拥有一个可以独立执行任务的机器人代理。所以当我谈论人类自主团队时，是指这个机器人代理、这个自主代理与人类伙伴的整合。那么这些团队在今天有多普遍？人类和机器人已经在一起工作的场景有哪些？
Sure, sure. I would say increasingly robots are being used in a variety of different domains. And this has been spurred by the decrease in costs and also the increased sophistication of these autonomous systems. So you can think about in the medical domain. You have robots like the Da Vinci. They assist surgeons in very precise surgeries. You can also think about in manufacturing or an assembly. They can lift heavy parts for their human teammate or they, They can be used to inspect items or products for defects. But robots are also being used widely in agriculture, for instance, or in search and rescue. Increasingly, we're using them in educational settings to help small children, particularly in STEM or children with learning disabilities. We can also see them in customer service. So maybe you've been to your recent supermarkets or large warehouse stores, you know, at Costco and things of that nature. you start to see them in different stores. I think they're even being used for some food preparation these days.
当然，当然。我想说，机器人正越来越多地被用于各种不同的领域。这得益于成本的降低以及这些自主系统复杂性的提高。你可以想想医疗领域。你有像达芬奇（Da Vinci）这样的机器人。它们协助外科医生进行非常精确的手术。你也可以想想制造业或装配业。它们可以为人类队友搬运沉重的零件，或者它们可以被用来检查物品或产品的缺陷。但机器人也被广泛用于农业，例如，或搜救。我们越来越多地在教育环境中使用它们来帮助幼儿，特别是在STEM领域或有学习障碍的儿童。我们也可以在客户服务中看到它们。所以也许你去过最近的超市或大型仓储商店，你知道，在Costco之类的地方，你开始在不同的商店看到它们。我想它们甚至在这些天被用于一些食品准备工作。
And of course, we all know autonomous cars, right? Autonomous vehicles. So lots of different applications for certain. So much of your work centers on trust in human robot teams. What role does trust play both in all human and in human robot teams? And why is it so important to be studying trust? Yes, yes. So trust has been found to lead.
当然，我们都知道自动驾驶汽车，对吧？自动驾驶车辆。所以确实有很多不同的应用。你的大部分工作都集中在人机团队的信任上。信任在全人类团队和人机团队中分别扮演什么角色？为什么研究信任如此重要？是的，是的。所以人们发现信任会导致
to better performance outcomes in teams. So teams that trust each other, they take more risks, they're more creative, they tend to have less conflict, they communicate well, they're able to conduct backup behaviors for one another, and all of this results in better performance outcomes. So in that sense, trust is this really critical element in terms of the relationship between not only individuals and robots, but between groups of people and a robot, or between groups of individuals and groups of robot. And indeed, trust is one of the biggest or most common variables that are measured when we're looking at the human robot interaction literature.
团队更好的绩效结果。因此，相互信任的团队会承担更多风险，更有创造力，冲突往往更少，沟通良好，能够为彼此提供备份行为，所有这些都会带来更好的绩效结果。因此，从这个意义上说，信任不仅在个人与机器人之间，而且在人群与机器人之间，或在人群与机器人群之间，都是一个非常关键的要素。事实上，当我们审视人机交互文献时，信任是测量到的最大或最常见的变量之一。
That literature has really, you know, taught us that when an autonomous system fails, performance is reduced, trust is degraded, and also workload increases. And so when you ask me, hey, why do we study trust? I guess I would say trust guides reliance, particularly in high complexity situations where unanticipated situations make a complete understanding of the autonomous system impractical. More and more robots are looking sort of humanoid, I think. And, you know, there's some research around whether the robot has to have a face or eyes or a mouth. I mean, does that increase trust? How do we react to a robot that's,
这些文献确实告诉我们，当自主系统失败时，绩效会降低，信任会下降，工作量也会增加。所以当你问我，嘿，我们为什么要研究信任？我想我会说信任指导依赖，特别是在复杂性高的情况下，不可预见的情况使得对自主系统的完全理解变得不切实际。越来越多的机器人看起来有点像人形，我想。而且，你知道，有一些关于机器人是否必须有脸、眼睛或嘴巴的研究。我的意思是，这会增加信任吗？我们如何对一个
too human or not human enough? Yeah, yeah, Kim, that's a great question. So there's a lot of research looking at anthropomorphize and robots, meaning making them more look like humans or animals. And a lot of that is used to embed some trust, to help facilitate trust between the human and the agent. So if you look at the domains of either education or when we impose robots with older adults,
太像人或不够像人的机器人做出反应？是的，是的，金，这是一个很好的问题。所以有很多研究关注机器人的拟人化，意思是让它们看起来更像人类或动物。其中很多被用来建立某种信任，以帮助促进人类与代理之间的信任。所以如果你看看教育领域，或者当我们把机器人与老年人放在一起时，
we tend to make them more childlike, more, you know, big eyes, for instance, or sometimes we use animals that are furry like the peril seal with older adults to comfort them. When you think about the military robotics, you want them to look strong and sturdy and capable. So how we trust an agent, really how it looks plays a big part of that. And certainly there's a lot of researchers looking at that. What other ways do human robot teams differ from all human teams? What are the particular challenges of working with robots? So I would say human, human teams, there is a lot of ways in which we communicate.
我们倾向于让它们更像孩子，你知道，大眼睛，例如，或者有时我们使用像海豹机器人（Paro）那样毛茸茸的动物来安慰老年人。当你想到军事机器人时，你希望它们看起来强壮、坚固且有能力。所以我们如何信任一个代理，它看起来如何确实起到了很大的作用。当然，有很多研究人员在研究这一点。人机团队与全人类团队还有哪些不同？与机器人合作的特殊挑战是什么？所以我想说，人与人的团队，我们沟通的方式有很多。
And so we can communicate verbally, give nonverbal cues. When we do something wrong, we work to repair and rebuild that trust in that relationship. And so when you're working with a robot or an autonomous system, I think some of the challenges are we don't necessarily want for the humans to always have to work around the robot. We want the robot to be able to also be agile. I'd say another challenge is when we study human robot teaming, we tend to do it with a dyad, meaning one person, one robot. And that's not really how we work in high critical safety environment. We work with a lot of different people. So we need to learn how to onboard that robot appropriately to a team.
所以我们可以口头交流，给出非语言暗示。当我们做错事时，我们会努力修复和重建那种关系中的信任。所以当你与机器人或自主系统合作时，我认为一些挑战在于我们不一定希望人类总是不得不绕着机器人工作。我们希望机器人也能灵活。我想说另一个挑战是，当我们研究人机协作时，我们倾向于用二元组，意味着一个人，一个机器人。而这并不是我们在高安全关键环境中工作的方式。我们与许多不同的人一起工作。所以我们需要学习如何适当地将机器人引入团队。
I think another issue is when we study these robots in the lab, usually it's one and done. A participant comes into the lab or even maybe a group of participants comes into the lab and then they leave. Or sometimes we have the ability to study robots for, you know, have participants come a few times or put a robot into a home or into a classroom, but we don't have these really long extended interactions. So we want to really look at that. I think the last thing I would say is field studies. So having the robots out working in the
我认为另一个问题是，当我们在实验室研究这些机器人时，通常是一次性的。参与者来到实验室，甚至可能是一组参与者来到实验室，然后他们就离开了。或者有时我们有能力研究机器人，你知道，让参与者来几次，或者把机器人放进家里或教室里，但我们没有这些真正长期的扩展互动。所以我们想真正看看这一点。我想我要说的最后一件事是实地研究。所以让机器人在
real world with humans doing real tasks. I think that's an other area where we really struggle as scientists to be able to do that. So as I mentioned in the introduction, you work at West Point. So you're doing a lot of work regarding the role of robots on the battlefield in other systems related to the military. Can you talk about the sorts of things that you're working on and where you see the future of robots in the military? Sure, absolutely. So a lot of the work I do at West Point involves using research as a vehicle for teaching. And so specifically, I'm interested in exposing my students to technologies that the Army is exploring to enhance soldier performance. And this ranges from virtual reality technologies to soldier equipment.
现实世界中与人类一起工作，执行真实的任务。我认为这是我们作为科学家真正难以做到的一点。正如我在介绍中提到的，你在西点军校工作。所以你在关于战场上机器人角色以及其他与军事相关系统方面做了很多工作。你能谈谈你正在研究的事情，以及你如何看待机器人未来的军事应用吗？当然，绝对可以。所以我在西点军校所做的大部分工作涉及将研究作为教学的工具。具体来说，我有兴趣让我的学生接触军队正在探索的旨在提高士兵表现的技术。这范围从虚拟现实技术到士兵装备。
For example, I'm working on a project with students a semester looking at body armor that's specifically designed for women. But as you mentioned, the bulk of my work largely focuses on autonomous systems. And so I'm currently looking at a quadrupedal robot, so a four-legged robot, and how to embed that with dismounted soldiers. So last summer, a team of myself, maybe we were six to ten of us, we went out into the field with a four-legged robot during cadets summer leader training, and we collected data on over 600 cadets interacting with this robot.
例如，我正在和一个学期的学生做一个项目，研究专门为女性设计的防弹衣。但正如你提到的，我大部分的工作主要集中在自主系统上。所以我目前正在研究一种四足机器人，即四足机器人，以及如何将其嵌入到下车作战的士兵中。所以去年夏天，我和我的团队，也许我们有六到十个人，在学员暑期领导力训练期间带着一个四足机器人去了实地，我们收集了超过600名学员与这个机器人互动的数据。
And we really just wanted to see, hey, what types of tasks is it useful for you? Does it slow a team down? Does it help with communication? Does it help them to reach their objective quicker, faster? And we saw the gamut of it. You know, we saw instances where you would see the robot in-line formation marching with the soldiers through the field. But then you saw when they would maybe use it as a decoy,
我们真的只是想看看，嘿，它对你有什么类型的任务有用？它会拖慢团队的速度吗？它有助于沟通吗？它能帮助他们更快、更早地达到目标吗？我们看到了各种各样的情况。你知道，我们看到了你会在实地看到机器人与士兵排成一线行军的例子。但随后你看到当他们可能把它用作诱饵时，
which isn't, you know, the smartest thing, I guess, from a dollar's perspective, right? But we saw really wonderful creative things where the students were sending it like through the back stairs so then they could get. eyes on to see what was happening in a room. And so that was really exciting just to see how they would use it. And so that's one area where, you know, I'm really interested in looking at not only how do we onboard this autonomous teammate, how does this autonomous teammate then impact how the team works, how the team communicates, how the team trust the robot, continues to trust each other, particularly because people have different types of what we call in the literal.
这并不是，你知道，从美元的角度来看最聪明的事情，对吧？但我们看到了非常美妙的创造性事情，学生们把它通过后楼梯发送，这样他们就可以获得视野，看看房间里发生了什么。所以看到他们如何使用它真是太令人兴奋了。所以这是一个领域，你知道，我真的很有兴趣研究我们不仅如何引入这个自主队友，这个自主队友如何影响团队的工作方式，团队如何沟通，团队如何信任机器人，继续信任彼此，特别是考虑到人们有不同类型的我们所说的文献中的
or dispositional trust, how they feel about a robot coming into a situation, how much they're going to trust it. And that we're finding in our data collection actually really plays out in how they then interact with it later in terms of, hey, this robot's really part of our team or it isn't. I'm going to utilize it this way because I trust it or I don't. In any event, a lot of my work right now is really looking at also what happens when a robot fails. How do we repair that trust? So one can think about violations in terms of the competency of an agent. So it fails because it's a technical problem or also an integrity violation where it fails because it doesn't follow our norms or cultural norms, if you will. And then how do, so how do we apply different repair strategies to this? And, you know, for some people,
或倾向性信任，他们对机器人进入某种情况的感觉，他们会多大程度上信任它。我们在数据收集过程中发现，这实际上确实影响了他们后来如何与它互动，即“这个机器人真的是我们团队的一部分”还是“它不是”。我要这样利用它，因为我信任它，或者我不信任它。无论如何，我现在的大部分工作确实也在研究当机器人失败时会发生什么。我们如何修复那种信任？所以人们可以从代理的能力方面考虑违规。所以它失败了，因为这是一个技术问题，或者也是一个诚信违规，因为它不遵循我们的规范或文化规范，如果你愿意的话。那么，我们如何将不同的修复策略应用于此？而且，你知道，对一些人来说，
providing a lot of information about why the robot failed is really important. But for others, it's like, hey, I'm really sorry. I'm going to do better next time or wasn't that big of a deal. Let's just keep going. So really this type of repair and how long that repair lasts in that relationship is really interesting for me to look at right now. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost.
提供大量关于机器人为什么失败的信息非常重要。但对其他人来说，就像是，嘿，我很抱歉。我下次会做得更好，或者那不是什么大不了的事。让我们继续前进。所以这种修复以及这种修复在那种关系中持续多久，对我来说确实非常有趣。
Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. I'm really fascinated by the idea of a quadrupedal robot. And, you know, I'm thinking back to earlier days in the military where they use dogs and horses as, you know, four-legged assistants.
或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在Hilton.com或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可节省20%，获得您期待的住宿。当您想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。您住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为您提供住宿。我对四足机器人的想法非常着迷。而且，你知道，我回想起军队早期的日子，他们使用狗和马作为，你知道，四足助手。
And I'm wondering whether the soldiers you're working with, are they reacting to a quadrupedal robot as if it's an animal? You know, there's certainly a reason why we made it look that way, right? So on the one hand, dogs have worked a lot with military soldiers. But really, the reason why it's quadrupedal is for technical reasons, right? It can upright itself if it falls over versus a tract or wheeled type of robot. Another thing that we found was when we put a yellow robot out there with them versus a robot that was camouflaged, they liked the camouflaged one better because it was more like them. It was part of their team.
我想知道，与你合作的士兵们是否把四足机器人当作动物来对待？你知道，我们把它设计成这样肯定是有原因的，对吧？一方面，狗与军人一起工作过很多次。但实际上，它之所以是四足的，是出于技术原因，对吧？与履带式或轮式机器人相比，它摔倒后可以自己站起来。我们还发现，当我们把一个黄色的机器人和另一个伪装过的机器人放在他们身边时，他们更喜欢伪装的那一个，因为它更像他们，是他们团队的一部分。
And this goes back to your previous question on the anthropopause. propomorphization of these tools. So I'm not sure if I answered your question there. No, you did. I mean, and that's very helpful. Do they give the robot's names? Do you give the robot a name? This is something else we're really exploring, right? So we call it Scout, because Scout means something to them. We don't want to give it a boy or a girl name per se. We want to keep it sort of gender neutral. Yeah. Can you, are you programming it in such a way that it won't do certain things? Like, let's say one soldier got ticked off at another soldier and said, Scout, go get him. Would the robot do that, or does it have some limits? So right now, our robot is controlled by the
这回到了你之前关于这些工具的拟人化的问题。所以我不太确定我是否回答了你的问题。不，你回答了。我的意思是，这非常有帮助。他们会给机器人起名字吗？你会给机器人起名字吗？这是我们正在深入探索的另一个方面。我们叫它“侦察兵”（Scout），因为这个名字对他们有意义。我们不想给它起一个男孩或女孩的名字。我们想保持某种性别中立。是的。你是否在编程时限制了它做某些事情？比如，假设一个士兵对另一个士兵生气了，说：“侦察兵，去收拾他。”机器人会这样做吗，还是它有一些限制？目前，我们的机器人是由
research team. So we call that Wizard of Oz in robotic terms. And the reason why we do that is, I think oftentimes soldiers are given a lot of equipment, and it takes a long time for them to learn how to use it. And sometimes they don't have the interest or time to learn. So right now we're just saying, hey, you know, the robot team is going to, you know, us researchers, we're going to control it. And these are the things it can and cannot do. And these are the things we would like you not to do to it, right? Because there's some research out there that people abuse a robot. So they'll kick it over or they'll do things like that.
研究团队控制的。在机器人领域，我们称之为“绿野仙踪”（Wizard of Oz）。我们这样做的原因是，我认为士兵们通常被分配了大量的装备，他们需要很长时间才能学会如何使用。有时他们没有兴趣或时间去学习。所以现在我们只是说，嘿，机器人团队将由我们研究人员来控制。这些是它可以做和不能做的事情。这些是我们希望你们不要对它做的事情，对吧？因为有一些研究表明人们会虐待机器人。所以他们会把它踢倒，或者做类似的事情。
So right now we're just trying to keep it pretty clean and really try to understand in terms of the specific mission or tasks that the cadets or soldiers are doing out in the field, how they would use this robot and what is impeding them including it sooner in some of the roles. Here's a futuristic question. Are we moving toward a time when robots would be the actual soldiers? You know, I think we, society, we would want to keep, you know, our sons and daughters safe, right? And so you look at the evolution of robots in the military. So we use them a lot for detonating bombs for decades, explosive ordinance disposal. We've used them as drones to go in and to survey areas that we can't get to or it's unsafe. for us to put soldiers on the ground. Increasingly, we're looking at what we call large room robots, which are big tanks.
所以现在我们只是尽量保持简单，并真正尝试去理解学员或士兵在实地执行特定任务时，他们将如何使用这个机器人，以及是什么阻碍了他们更早地将其纳入某些角色。这是一个关于未来的问题。我们是否正在走向机器人成为真正士兵的时代？你知道，我认为我们社会希望保护我们的儿女安全，对吧？所以你看看军事中机器人的演变。几十年来，我们大量使用它们来引爆炸弹，即爆炸物处理。我们使用它们作为无人机进入我们无法到达或对士兵来说不安全的区域进行侦察。我们越来越多地关注所谓的“大型房间机器人”，也就是大型坦克。
And so the idea is that it would be a surrogate tank going in with our tank, and that would reduce the number of soldiers and units that we have out in dangerous areas. And so will a robot take over a human role? Will the robot take over a soldier role? I think these are very dangerous and complex situations. And so the creativity that humans have, the ability to solve problems, the experience that they have, certainly with the advent of AI, the pattern recognition has certainly surpassed human capability. However, we want that human to be in the loop in making these very difficult life and death decisions. But can we send robots to support soldiers?
所以我们的想法是，它将成为与我们坦克一起行动的替代坦克，这将减少我们在危险区域的士兵和单位数量。那么机器人会取代人类的角色吗？机器人会取代士兵的角色吗？我认为这些是非常危险和复杂的情况。人类所拥有的创造力、解决问题的能力、经验，当然随着人工智能的出现，模式识别能力肯定已经超过了人类。然而，我们希望人类能够参与到这些非常困难的生死决策中。但是我们能派遣机器人来支援士兵吗？
Absolutely. That's our intent. are right now. So I have to ask, how did you get involved in robotics and what was your route to West Point? Yes, thanks for asking this. So I did my graduate work in D.C. I was looking at decision support tools for air traffic controllers. While in grad school, I did a few small projects for the Army Research Lab. And I'm originally from New York and a job opened up at West Point to teach. I actually was not looking for an academic position. I thought I was going to go work for Boeing or someone making stuff for aviation or air traffic
当然可以。这就是我们的意图。那么我必须问，你是如何接触到机器人技术的，你的西点军校之路是怎样的？是的，谢谢你问这个问题。我在华盛顿特区完成了研究生学业。我当时研究的是空中交通管制员的决策支持工具。在读研期间，我为陆军研究实验室做了一些小项目。我来自纽约，西点军校有一个教学职位空缺。我其实并没有在寻找学术职位。我以为我会去波音公司或类似的地方，制造航空或空中交通方面的产品。
control. And I said, you know what, I'm going to give this a try. I was just so curious about it. And I arrived here. And two things, the students, phenomenal young men and women. I mean, you tell them the bar is here and they will jump much higher. The types of research I'm able to do with them is just incredible because they're just so bright and curious and interested. And I think part of that is me being able to.
控制设备。我说，你知道吗，我要试一试。我对此非常好奇。我来到这里。有两件事，学生们，非常出色的年轻人。我的意思是，你给他们设定一个标准，他们会跳得更高。我能与他们一起进行的研究简直令人难以置信，因为他们非常聪明、好奇且感兴趣。我认为部分原因是我能够。
The second thing is I'm able to work on real world tools. So tools that my cadets are going to see in a year, in two years, in three years, in five, in ten. And in fact, I have cadets email me back now and they're like, hey, I just got IVAS to my unit. And I'm actually ripping it out of the boxes and showing my teammates how to use it. And they're getting different types of hearing protection devices or that sort of thing. So what has kept me here really is the ability to work on real world tools and applications and change lives for soldiers in the field and also the students and the colleagues that I get to work with. Let's talk for a minute about the way that most of us interact with robots and AI in daily life today.
第二件事是我能够研究现实世界的工具。也就是我的学员在一年、两年、三年、五年、十年后会看到的工具。事实上，现在有学员给我发邮件说，嘿，我的单位刚收到IVAS（综合视觉增强系统）。我正在把它从盒子里拿出来，向我的队友展示如何使用它。他们正在获得不同类型的听力保护装置之类的东西。所以真正让我留在这里的是能够研究现实世界的工具和应用，并改变前线士兵的生活，以及我能与之共事的学生和同事。让我们花点时间谈谈我们大多数人今天在日常生活中与机器人和人工智能互动的方式。
are we losing skills in some areas because we become robot or AI dependent? For example, there's no need for us to memorize phone numbers anymore. We don't need to be able to read maps to drive someplace. Is this a problem? Yes, Kim. I would say, you know, deskilling is real. It is a problem. You know, certainly you can think of in the aviation industry.
我们是否因为变得依赖机器人或人工智能而在某些领域丧失了技能？例如，我们不再需要记住电话号码了。我们开车去某个地方不需要会看地图。这是一个问题吗？是的，Kim。我会说，技能退化是真实存在的。这是一个问题。你知道，当然你可以想到航空业。
They experience this deskilling issue for pilots. as the cockpit became increasingly automated. You know, pilots got caught over-relying on the technology, leading to catastrophic results. So in emergency situations where pilots needed to revert to manual flying, they were sometimes caught out of the loop, meaning they didn't know what was going on, where they were spatially,
随着驾驶舱自动化程度越来越高，飞行员也遇到了这种技能退化的问题。你知道，飞行员过度依赖技术，导致了灾难性的后果。因此，在飞行员需要恢复手动驾驶的紧急情况下，他们有时会脱离循环，这意味着他们不知道发生了什么，他们在空间上的位置，
why a particular alert was sounding off and so forth. So as a result, the FAA and the airlines, they recommended that pilots fly manually to maintain this proficiency. They also have training simulators that have built in scenarios where pilots need to quickly recover and take over this manual control during emergency situations. So, you know, we've learned a lot of lessons from the aviation industry, especially human factors professionals. We have studied how individuals work with technology for decades. But really, we've really focused. on highly trained individuals. And so now when these tools are available to the masses, we really
为什么某个警报在响等等。因此，美国联邦航空管理局（FAA）和航空公司建议飞行员手动飞行以保持这种熟练度。他们还有内置场景的训练模拟器，要求飞行员在紧急情况下迅速恢复并接管手动控制。所以，我们从航空业学到了很多教训，特别是人为因素专家。几十年来，我们一直在研究个人如何与技术合作。但实际上，我们真正关注的是受过高度训练的个人。所以现在当这些工具普及到大众时，我们真的
have to be a bit more weary or maybe more focused on how this impacts people. I guess here's one of my main concerns is there is a widening gap that we're seeing, particularly when we think about generative AI between the expert and the novice. So generative AI gives us outputs as an expert. If it's on psychology or human factors, I can say, hey, that's not really right or it's missing something very critical. My students, on the other hand, they can't identify that just yet. So I think there is this widening gap between experts and novice that we have to be aware of. So we're not going to lose all of our thinking ability. we hope.
必须更加谨慎，或者更加关注这对人们的影响。我想我主要担心的一点是，我们正在看到一个日益扩大的差距，特别是在考虑生成式人工智能时，专家和新手之间的差距。生成式人工智能作为专家给我们输出结果。如果是在心理学或人为因素方面，我可以判断，嘿，那不太对，或者它缺少了一些非常关键的东西。另一方面，我的学生还无法识别这一点。所以我认为专家和新手之间存在这种日益扩大的差距，我们必须意识到这一点。所以我们不会失去所有的思考能力，我们希望如此。
Right. Now, I mean, speaking of, you know, the robots and AI taking over all kinds of tasks that we have traditionally done ourselves, do you envision that we'll ever have fully automated self-driving cars or will there always be a need for some human oversight in such a complex task as driving? Yeah, I think a lot of people feel a lot of strong ways about this. you know, I think this is a great question. I think self-driving cars are exciting. Who does not want to sit back and eat a snack and watch a movie on a long-distance drive? I think this is absolutely going to be a game changer potentially for older adults. It'll help them to get out and be more social or to get to their medical appointments to the supermarket without having to be dependent on others. But I think while there's a lot of goodness, we're not there yet. And this really gets back. to a serious safety concern or issue in that drivers are going to be caught over trust in these autonomous systems. So as human factors professionals, we're left to sort out issues like trust. And so I think, you know, one thing I haven't shared much with you yet today is I'm studying
对。现在，说到机器人和人工智能接管我们传统上自己完成的各种任务，你认为我们是否会拥有完全自动化的自动驾驶汽车，还是在驾驶这样复杂的任务中总是需要某种人类监督？是的，我认为很多人对此有强烈的看法。你知道，我认为这是一个很好的问题。我认为自动驾驶汽车令人兴奋。谁不想在长途驾驶时坐下来吃零食看电影呢？我认为这绝对有可能成为老年人的游戏规则改变者。它将帮助他们走出去，变得更善于社交，或者在不必依赖他人的情况下前往医疗预约地点或超市。但我认为虽然有很多好处，但我们还没有达到那个阶段。这确实回到了一个严重的安全性担忧或问题，即驾驶员会因为过度信任这些自动系统而陷入困境。作为人为因素专家，我们必须解决信任之类的问题。所以我认为，你知道，今天我还没和你分享的一件事是我正在研究
individual differences in normal cognition. And researchers are finding that trust is influenced by these individual differences, for instance, work in memory or control of attention. And so with the advent of autonomous systems being available to the masses, individuals with too little training, we really need to understand how these basic individual differences may play into over-reliance on some systems. Yeah, I'm always struck by the choices that an autonomous car has to be programmed to make. And I'm thinking of, say, the trolley experiment, you know, very famous in psychology. Like, how does an autonomous vehicle make a decision between whether it runs into a person in a crosswalk or takes another evasive action?
正常认知中的个体差异。研究人员发现，信任受到这些个体差异的影响，例如工作记忆或注意力控制。因此，随着自动系统普及到大众，对于训练不足的个人，我们确实需要了解这些基本的个体差异如何导致对某些系统的过度依赖。是的，我总是对自动驾驶汽车必须被编程做出的选择感到震惊。我在想，比如电车难题，你知道，在心理学中非常有名。自动驾驶汽车如何在撞向人行横道上的人还是采取其他规避行动之间做出决定？
Yeah, and to loop this back to some of the work that I'm doing on trust, depending on how that autonomous vehicle makes that decision, what it decides to prioritize. Is it going to prioritize, you know, a dog or is it going to prioritize a ball or a small child or a bicycle or an oncoming ambulance? You know, that gets into when I was talking earlier about different types of trust violations. So, for instance, that would be what I would classify as an integrity violation because it is violating my norm as a user. but we all have different norms as users. So I think really those types of decisions or prioritization of these autonomous systems and what decisions and outcomes are making, we really need to study a little bit more
是的，为了将其与我正在进行的一些关于信任的研究联系起来，取决于自动驾驶汽车如何做出该决定，它决定优先考虑什么。它是优先考虑狗，还是优先考虑球、小孩、自行车或迎面而来的救护车？你知道，这涉及到我之前谈到的不同类型的信任违规。例如，我会将其归类为诚信违规，因为它违反了作为用户的我的规范。但我们作为用户都有不同的规范。所以我认为，这些自动系统的决策或优先级排序，以及它们正在做出什么样的决定和结果，我们确实需要多研究一点
how humans would respond to it, how repair will happen, and how long that repair can last. A moment ago we talked a little bit about the human-robot relationship, where there are these companions, say for older people or people with Alzheimer's or other, you know, cognitive issues. And I'm just wondering whether you believe a robot can really provide companionship in a way that another human might. I'd have to say no. I think certainly they can fill a space. They can provide some companionship. But in the end, we are social beings. and we need to be with others. You know, I think we've learned a lot of lessons from the pandemic
人类将如何反应，修复将如何发生，以及这种修复能持续多久。刚才我们谈到了一点人机关系，比如为老年人或患有阿尔茨海默病或其他认知问题的人提供陪伴。我只是想知道你是否认为机器人真的能像另一个人那样提供陪伴。我不得不说不。我认为它们当然可以填补空间。它们可以提供一些陪伴。但最终，我们是社会性生物，我们需要与他人在一起。你知道，我认为我们从大流行中学到了很多教训
about the importance of interacting with others. You know, we're seeing a lot of lessons coming out of having adolescents move from being out in the environment, interacting with one another, to being in their homes and interacting with virtual agents or only online. So I see a robot as a tool, you know. yes, it can be my teammate, but to do a task. There's a goal we have in mind. So similarly, when I think
关于与他人互动的重要性。你知道，我们看到很多教训来自于青少年从在环境中与他人互动，转变为待在家里只与虚拟代理或仅在网上互动。所以我把机器人看作一种工具。是的，它可以是我的队友，但那是为了完成任务。我们心中有一个目标。所以同样地，当我想到
about, you know, a robot with maybe, say, an older adult, well, you know, not all of us can have our parents living with us or maybe we live many states away from our parents, but knowing that a robot can help our older adults lift heavy things or do these types of tasks that may be more difficult for them, I think that's certainly helpful and useful. I think the more social pieces are really hard. And certainly, I think there's a lot of research being done right now on social robotics, right? That interaction piece for older adults, for younger children, and even just for anybody, for everybody. And the more that we're able to learn about that, the more we're able to embed these social components with robots, then the better that interaction is going to be.
关于机器人与老年人的相处，嗯，你知道，并不是我们所有人都能让父母和我们住在一起，或者也许我们住的地方离父母很远，但知道机器人可以帮助我们的老年人搬运重物或做这些对他们来说可能更困难的任务，我认为这当然是有帮助和有用的。我认为社交方面确实很难。当然，我认为目前关于社交机器人有很多研究，对吧？针对老年人、幼儿，甚至针对任何人、所有人的互动部分。我们对这些了解得越多，我们就越能将这些社交组件嵌入到机器人中，那么互动就会越好。
But are people replaceable in the end in terms of a companion? I'm not really buying that one. No. Even if I totally programmed a robot to act like Dr. Rivera, it still wouldn't be as good as spending time with you? Well, I hope not, Kim. Well, let me ask you just to Crystal Ball a little bit as we wrap up here. What are you working on, where do you see robotics in the next 10 or 20 years,
但最终人们在陪伴方面是可替代的吗？我不太相信这一点。不。即使我完全把机器人编程得像Rivera博士一样，它仍然不会像和你在一起那样好吗？嗯，我希望不是，Kim。好吧，在我们结束之前，让我请你预测一下未来。你正在研究什么，你认为机器人技术在未来10到20年内会发展到什么程度，
particularly related to the kinds of work that you're doing at West Point? I think what would be really fascinating to understand more of or more about is multiple robots working with multiple humans and that interplay and the dynamics of that interplay being successful, I think that would be very exciting. Well, Dr. Riviera, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think the work you're doing is just amazing. Thanks a lot. Great. Thank you. I really enjoyed my time with you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas
特别是与你在西点军校所做的工作相关？我认为更深入了解多个机器人与多个人类合作，以及这种互动和互动动态的成功，会是非常迷人的，我认为那将非常令人兴奋。好吧，Rivera博士，我要感谢你今天加入我。我认为你所做的工作非常了不起。非常感谢。太棒了。谢谢。我真的很享受和你在一起的时光。你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你有评论或想法
for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对于未来的播客，你可以发送电子邮件至Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。